good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
and i'm wishing you a very happy friday
friday gotta get down on friday
today is such a special day for so many
reasons first and foremost
the bruno in the room bruiseldorf sweets
is here
he dressed for the part he got all
dressed up he was like mom i know i'm
coming to work with you today and i just
like want to look my best and so we
picked out his outfit can you showcase
his outfit he chose to go with a suit
and tie um he just
is a professional guy that's what i love
most about brew it's like he really kind
of respects the toast
and you know you can always tell when
someone comes to the studio whether
they're a visitor or a guest
when they kind of like dress down they
think like low of us yeah and bruce only
thinks the highest of his mum and auntie
it's so true he's so happy to be here
let me get my big knee out of the way
say hi bro he's being so cute it's so
nice to have him here it's so nice to
have him here like
it's a tree for me to be able to bring
him really special for me obviously i'm
a little stressed
we miss theo so much we really really do
but he took a back seat
and that's okay because pups is working
from home today so
pups and pups are all together yeah we
just swapped one out for another so if
you're watching with your furry friend
at home
like let them know things have changed
we have a stunt double today no
literally
he looks so [ __ ] cute if you're
listening as a podcast highly suggest
just moving over to youtube really
quickly because bruce's face is so cute
and he's wearing a little doggy tie
and it might be the cutest thing i've
ever seen in my life it's really so cute
we'll leave we'll get one for theo and
hopefully
one day they'll both be able to co-exist
together on the show but right now like
brew would just
go crazy well while brew licks himself
i'm excited for today's show we've got a
great show
we do also it is good friday which i
have
learned is actually not um like a good
holiday it's quite somber it's the day
christ died for their sins right so
i wish you all a good but somber friday
yeah
and then a you know a celebratory easter
yes where he has risen
right oh yeah where he will have risen
right got it okay well
happy holidays to everybody so many
holidays going on right now i know
there's always like a crossover between
um passover and easter and it's nice
like we all get a few days off
or none at all which is how this year is
going right like
but i guess good friday and palm sunday
like always land on the weekend
yeah that stinks though because you
don't get off work then and that's
where we were at this year two seders on
the weekends that's true
last week i was so jam-packed this
weekend i just have you know
a long stretch in front of me and i've
really been taking the time to
acknowledge the space that i'm in where
it's like
two days alarm free living like how am i
gonna make the most of that time right
now that's a really important kind of
perspective to take um i do feel as
though i should remind you that tomorrow
um is ben's birthday so i don't know if
there's you don't really have to do
anything i know but like you haven't put
me on the hook for anything no because
it's the holiday so like ben doesn't
really want to do anything right
so again i just want to say you know
like you have a lot of free living but
you do have a text message to send at
midnight that i can do what midnight i
don't actually know i've
actually been staying up so late like
i'm so crazy night owl
night owl um so i think i could i can
send that text okay well this is also
just like everyone's reminder maybe you
know
send me a message do something nice for
him yeah donate to
the anti-bill de blasio fund that's all
you can do for ben on his birthday
in lieu of gifts this year he just wants
you to make a donation to the anti-bill
de blasio fund what will you be doing
for ben's birthday
um i don't know i literally have nothing
to do with him
yeah your love and support no i got him
gift it's not here yet but i got it
okay cool okay i won't like press you
clearly like this is sore subject yeah
no i just know there's like a bunch of
snitchy ass toasters
who every time i talk about ben they
like run his dm's and ben's like what'd
you say about me on the toes today
because not for me he listens god forbid
he listens it's the same thing with
snitching so i'm just not really going
to talk about my personal life
because of the snitchy ass toasters stop
um
speaking of sore subjects that i don't
think need to be sore for you
no what what what are you talking about
you got a haircut oh yeah
oh yeah i got a haircut sorry i thought
you're talking about something else
um what i got a haircut and what could
possibly elicit i'll tell you later i'll
tell you later
because i don't want to bring it up you
know um yes i got a haircut a quick chop
a little shorter than i was planning on
going but i think it's just a fresh
chop for the summer i love it thank you
so much and it definitely feels lighter
and healthier and
it's so important to cut your hair twice
a year you know yeah at least
i'm learning that recently the more you
cut it the longer it gets like yeah look
at my hair
i'm now like a reminder we're heading
into april well we are in april like
summer's really around the corner and if
you want like that fresh chop
i like to get my hair cut a little early
because like usually a month after my
hair cut
i find like the perfect length for
myself and so in a month it's really
going to be
summer already and then i will have my
perfect summer length so i don't know
who needs to hear this but book your
hair appointment summer's around the
corner and you need that fresh summer
chop
you do you really do yeah we have a
great show for you today kardashians was
on last night
i watched bruno watched too so he'll be
a part of the recap
and other than that um the mcplant is
doing a show behind you i think i'm
gonna go grab him if you wanna
if you wanna grace us with a song sure
no um no worries take your time it's
okay
um i mean i did sing on my instagram
story when we were young by adele
yesterday
but i won't torture you guys because as
many messages as i got from people who
were like damn you're such a good singer
i also got a lot of messages from people
being like for the love of god
please stop singing so jackie's back and
i can
turn it over to her oh that was so not
graceful
i know sorry podcasters i just like sat
on my mic mcplant is turning out to be
like a little bit of a torture thing
with the dogs
a torture he's a torturer and it's like
we're
fighting for competition with mcplant i
know it's like i love mcplant more than
anything
and bloomscape is one of my favorite
sponsors but it is
becoming a burden it's the plant or the
dogs like yeah and i think we're gonna
have to choose
our sweet love the plant no kidding hi
sweet bruce
um so just like while bruce is here i
just want to give like a little bruising
should we do like a little q a with bro
oh my god he would like
a brewery a brewing a do you have cues
in bruce
sure hey bruce how you doing darn good
um bruce how was life in new york city
do you feel like you missed life on the
farm or you feel like you won the
jackpot in terms of parents
i won the jackpot in terms of parents
but i do wish they would move
yeah of course of course yeah and how is
it jacob tremblay being out of your room
for the first time
well you know recently i've gotten a
very busy schedule being a quarantine
baby you know at first i never
left your house but now as things start
to open up my schedule is just
wide open yesterday i had exercise and
then i went to the spa it was so
fabulous
and brew tell me about some of your
cousins i hear one of them
has a really really really famous mom oh
yeah and he definitely like holds it
over the rest of us
because whenever me and knowles that's
my girlfriend knowles
whenever we're with theo we just want to
hang out with him and not be kids but
he's like i'm famous i'm on the show
every morning
and we're like we love you for who you
are not for what you do theo
that's why he's not interested he only
is interested in friends who love him
for what he does
but um they just want to be like you
know
close for for real reasons bru how long
have you and your girlfriend
been together and how far have you gone
have you gone to second base yet well we
made it official over the holidays
and we are holiday romance we're taking
things slow
okay is she uh i don't spade i don't
kiss and tell ooh
well thank you for being here you're
free to go no you're never free to go my
sweet sweet brew
um so i think maybe we should just dive
right in without further ado
yeah okay if you say so
bruh what do you think that's a yes yes
without further ado it's time for the
fast life stories that you need to know
and brew needs to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
i don't know why you don't say without
further ado
without further ado today's episode is
brought to you by our patreon channel
you guys if you're not sure what our
patreon channel is it is our premium
subscription service
so the morning toast is here five days a
week completely free forever but if
you're looking for more content from
jackie i the scenes the dogs
all the family members we choose to
exploit then head over to patreon.com
your morning toast for 7.99 per month
you can become a premium member and get
five extra episodes vlog episodes
podcast episodes from jackie and i
more in depth more behind the scenes and
you also get access to the last
remaining facebook group on planet earth
the toast after dark which is like the
only safe space on the internet and it
has become one of my favorite things
ever so
7.99 gets you access to the facebook
group and five extra episodes a month
from us it's a great way to support the
show
and get more premium content so that's
patreon.com
the morning toast love it okay
first story we survived april fools and
i want to talk about some of the best
celeb and brand pranks and then any of
the worst if you if you came across any
yeah i did the best prank for me is our
first story
michael strahan reveals his teeth gap is
here to stay
in april fool's day prank this was
really um
brilliant this got me a few days ago we
saw a video that he posted um
he got his gap filled film
yeah and no say goodbye said goodbye to
the gap and then yesterday he revealed
that it was an april fool's day prank
and that like he would never
but he was smart because he did the
video about the gap closed on march 31st
like people weren't in the april fool's
headspace i was
not in the april fool's head space at
all and i think when he posted it like
people
you know felt a lot of different ways
about it and some people were feeling
rdh like they love that gap
yeah no i think for the most part people
were like no like and even like when i
was thinking i'm like it's so cool to
like become so successful
with not that like with a unique i don't
know what the right word is like with
an imperfection if you will and like
it's become his signature thing and he
became so successful was it with it so
like i understand someone
wanting to like fix an imperfection like
with the hopes of becoming successful
but like to reach the top of your game
like with like being known for your
signature
look look and then change it i'm like to
each their own of course and i support
anyone who wants to make any sort of
cosmetic
yeah decision but i was just like oh no
yeah i think a lot of people felt that
way and then
he let them know that it was just a
prank which i loved i thought it was
brilliant i thought it was a brilliant
it was my personal favorite prank of the
day just because it
really got me but then my other favorite
prank of the day which wasn't a prank on
me we just got to watch the video was
caitlyn bristow
pulled the most amazing pr i agree on
her businessman beau jason tardik
i agree you guys have to head to her
instagram video to watch it but
basically
she she planned it perfectly she sent
him a nude the night before
and she texted 30 of his friends from
like all different parts different
sizes like home bath child work exactly
mutual friends and they all texted him
around the same time like jason did you
mean to post that
and literally the best one was jillian
harris she's like
hey jason it's jillian harris i didn't
have your number but i found it in some
group text i just wanted to like reach
out and double check like you meant to
post that on your instagram
yes which is the most painful text
message
you can ever receive 100
so he's like facetiming with her he's
getting these texts he's like hold on
gotta go and she like hangs up and is
laughing
and then he's like people are saying i
posted something on my instagram story
and like then she goes to and she's like
oh my god jason and he's like
and she had to send him she had sent him
the day before like a sexy photo
and so of course that he accidentally
posted that he literally
when he's screaming what oh oh sorry
bruce i didn't mean to scare you that's
what it sounded like come here bro
by the way also if you listen to our
patreon episode from last month um
the final episode we talked like for 20
minutes about bruce's really special
bark and you guys just got to hear it
a little bit of it but it be it's become
a little more mature manly manly yeah
but i i love that old park
well back to caitlyn it was sickening
it was sickening go watch it for
yourself i've watched it so many times
cackling and then jason put up a video
like explaining like
what was going on in history it was all
the texts that people sent and the text
are
like it was so well done so well
executed kudos to the tartic bristow
family 100 what were some of your other
favorites
favorites i loved caitlin's i loved
michael strahan's and i thought
tiffany's did like a really cute job
they basically
unveiled their new they're known for
their kind of blue green
teal signature color they own the color
it's the color of all their boxes the
color of all their stores tiffany blue
it's tiffany blue
they own the color and they redesigned
like their whole box to like this new
pantone yellow
and said like this was the new yellow of
the brand and it was like for a second i
was like oh that's interesting then i'm
like oh it's april fool's
and i actually thought it was like a
harmless fun prank yes
on the other side um we did have a
where are the harmful ones we spoke
yesterday like kind of just like praying
no celebrities or influencers we're
going to do like a fake pregnancy
because it's just
it's just not funny um and unfortunately
i believe tori spelling
um fell prey and i don't she didn't come
out and say that she was kidding yet but
she was doing m sculpt on her belly like
two days ago which you cannot do if
you're pregnant
let me actually just check her instagram
to like double check and the caption was
just number six and people were like
really upset in the comments like if she
was making this into
a april fools it's definitely april
fools it's still
up i think six thousand comments no
no word from her well it's still early
in l.a maybe she's sleeping
and it's like she hasn't been awake on
april 2nd yet but do you if you play a
prank do you reveal it on
the second or like the evening of the
first oh i think i would reveal it on
the second okay that's why i like
michael strahan's he did it before and
then revealed on the first and like
caught us off guard yeah but what if
this becomes like one of those things
where april fools just moves up and up
every single
year you know it's like oh they expect
on march 31st march 30th right that's
the thing that's frustrating and like
unfortunately for michael strahan it
worked in his benefits like i think a
lot of people will like take
inspiration from that but all pranks
should be reserved for just the first
and you can't have spillover from you
know the 31st or the 30th
it's not fair yes it's in general but i
i'll let this one slide
yeah they're also just like harmless
pranks like the tiffany ones like the
michael strahan ones
and then there are ones that like have
larger cultural implications like the
tory spelling one and it's just
i think we're beyond that and i get like
annoyed with pranks but some like the
michael strahan won the calendar one
like those are harmless
so i thought they were really funny and
in good fun 100 like a
plus perfection immaculate or i don't
want it
i know but just like after this year
like i'm just like and no place to joke
do you know what i mean
i don't know something about this year
has just like totally done like an april
fool's reset for me
and i felt like i was as open to the day
as i've ever been
no i actually think for the first time i
was as closed as i've ever been
to the whole prank community i feel like
before kovid we had just
built up such a high tolerance for these
things and like brands were like always
doing the most and like
we had a reset and now it's like some
good jokes okay
no okay well well it's over it's over
we have 364 days acknowledge the space
we're in we're as far away from april
fools as we'll ever be
and we're pretty acknowledged that we're
also pretty far away from yom kippur so
we should acknowledge that as well
and we're soon to be far away from pesos
oh that's true that's a good feeling
yeah by the way and by the next time you
see us after this today's show like we
will be able to eat bread so like just
know my face will be like way puffier
i've been so good like last night i
really thought about like just cheating
and having some rice which
in certain parts of the jewish community
are considered kinney oat and are
allowed like
certain more um sphartic communities are
allowed to have corn and rice but we're
astronauts like we have to go all the
way ham
and usually sometimes i do let myself
have rice and pretend that i'm spartik
like but i'm not
and i was planning on having rice last
night but instead i just had like a lot
of alcohol and
it really helped also works yeah it
worked nice well yeah we're so close it
really hasn't been like that difficult
actually but like
i don't know i just feel like i haven't
been able to be creative and i'm just
eating so much matzah
yeah that's the thing it's really hard
to be creative with like your food
choices when you're limit like you can't
have pasta you can't have flour like
you don't realize how like bread even in
its non-traditional form
is literally a part of every [ __ ]
like culinary
experience experience i agree and for
brew it's been really difficult
and he's been having a lot of matzah he
will like sprinkle some kibble on his
matzah
and it's like a nice treat for him
that's [ __ ] sick
yucking his yum yes yes that's [ __ ]
yucking you're going to bind him up like
that giving him matzah
for those who are listening to earlier
issues for those who listened to earlier
in the week the word i was looking for
was
binding when it comes to matzah really
kind of binds up your insides makes it
very hard to go number two
but it was really confusing because you
described the feeling as feeling bound
so we thought you like knew the word
yeah okay ready for our next story yeah
it's a little music news
a little move moose olivia rodrigo
releases her new song deja vu it's the
first song since her debut hit
driver's license so
deja vu her next song is out she also
announced that she has an album coming
soon
um driver's license as you all know we
have chronicled the
meteoric the success of the song and it
has just taken the world by storm
she hasn't released the album title yet
but those on tick tock have discovered
that its name is sour
well i would say that about sums it up
yeah that
sums up this song i listened to the song
this morning deja vu i hadn't listened
to it yet
and at first i was like not feeling it i
thought the lyrics were like
everything of the sort like very taylor
swift kind of we love
you know a very casey musk graves like
telling a story
um but like the beat wasn't working for
me but then as the song kind of
escalates like the bridge it definitely
got a lot better and i need to listen to
it a few times but
it wasn't an instant hit for me but i do
think i will grow to love it
that's so interesting i had the opposite
experience i didn't mind the bop itself
and i thought that the lyrics were an
interesting choice considering they're
very much like
about sabrina and joshua once again
we're going harder yeah oh no i don't
agree because there was a lyric that was
like and her name sounds just like mine
olivia sabrina oh
yeah and they're both actresses and like
i think it's still about sabrina it's
like the strawberry ice cream and the
you know was there strawberry ice cream
motifs in some of her other music no but
like she's talking about the things that
they used to do and like it's only been
so much time like and he's still with
sabrina so now she's just like saying do
you have deja vu
she's still with sabrina like there's no
they were promoting each other's stuff
they've been promoting ah wow this
better be like the sabrina's a bigger
woman than i am because
i would leave that little shrimp in two
[ __ ] seconds
but all the trouble he's caused her okay
so i want to just continue
just my train of thought i'm sorry
because the song is like very much going
ham like still about sabrina and joshua
and like i felt like when sabrina put
out her song
which by the way i'm obsessed with the
song skin like just as much as driver's
license personally just saying no that's
like a very unique to you it's
a very yeah right but she got a lot of
like flack for it being like you know
sort of like taunting like yes i'm going
so hard like he's all over my skin yeah
and i feel like olivia is doing that
exact same thing
right back to her and it's like for all
the criticism that sabrina got olivia
chose that same motif of being like
yeah but that that is in a way what you
should do first yeah
you know yeah i just like i can't get
into it like i just can't get into it
like these are literal teenagers you
know what i mean like
i have just chosen the olivia rodrigo
side and i don't really feel like i have
an explanation for why or how or whether
like i can't justify it i just like i
choose her always i
choose i mean the world has she has
chosen her i know it's like sad for the
others
dave what's his name joshua bassett i
was gonna call him david
joshua bassett put up a tick tock
yesterday um 12 hours ago which is
interesting timing it's when the song
came out except that i saw him like
snitch his instagram
deja vu like the other day it came out
thursday okay but she like was posting
from spotify i just want to say
who snitch yesterday oh it came out
yesterday thursday yeah it was weird for
a song not to come out on a friday okay
thank you
but um joshua bassett made a tick tock
it was just like a selfie video and he
was like you know what i just found out
this is crazy the world actually like
doesn't revolve around you
crazy right and so of course now we're
all reading into it like who is the you
olivia like not i guess he's trying to
say like not everything's about you
but i don't know olivia's entitled to
like feel her own feeling she's like a
young girl experiencing a heartbreak
like
and she's just like expressing that
through her art i don't think it's that
crazy but
it just stops at the narrative the world
has taken on like
villainizes joshua and sabrina to the
nth degree because like i'm
like i'm as i'm a sabrina supporter in
addition to olivia and like
i don't think there's so many of us but
even i a sabrina supporter like still
have
no space for joshua no that's the thing
like of all the people in this kind of
saga like the person i really feel bad
for
is sabrina carpenter the person i
absolutely adore is olivia rodrigo
the person who's like i'm so indifferent
like i could like like never see him
again joshua bassett
yeah not only that like i kind of don't
like him i know he's a child so i
shouldn't say that but
well he's over 18. he is over 18 and i
think that's actually a great segue into
our next story
okay james charles no oh bad baby
oh do you have james charles story no
you wanna just give you a
brief rundown i know you don't really
care about like youtube drama well
it's not that i don't care it's just
like every time we'll like literally sit
down and like talk about it and then the
next day everything changes turns out
everything wasn't true and it's like i
just
i can't keep no i know i can't keep
going back and forth
yeah i i 100 agree with you like that's
why
and this is so random but like over the
summer there was like all this drama
with factor like i never really got into
it because like it was two
two layers it really was and now it's
like everything that like came out about
it was like false so like i'm so glad i
did you see no i haven't seen the latest
no so like like olivia was catching me
up on it and like i was trying to like
read something like rodrigo or australia
because she's like keeping up on it
right um i just like i i'm so glad i
didn't get invested in this whole story
because it turns out like half the
claims were like completely untrue and
like
there's like i don't even know i can't
speak on it but like that's the type of
thing where it's like such a layered
complicated
right you have to watch like literally
200 instagram highlights and i'm not
doing that okay but question
um but this james charleston is not as
layered okay but i
last i had heard about the factor stuff
like tanya was suing
the person who like exposed everything
right how's that going
um still going and i think
don't quote me on this because i'm i'm
not there are people who could literally
do a three-hour podcast on it i'm not
one of those people i'm just like trying
to
stay catch up you're trying to stay
abreast it's what we're all doing
so much okay as far as i have heard and
again
not 100 sure is that tanya is like
winning in the legal space
okay um because so many of the claims
that were made about
factor were unfounded and like coming
from fake accounts
and people who might have had like a bad
reaction to her products
don't want to speak out legally like
they just are regular people they just
like want to live their lives
yeah they don't want to like become a
witness yeah right it's like so
complicated
so um now like the tides are turning for
effect or like
maybe like people are saying like and
again i'm not sure if any of this is
true but this is just what the people
are saying is gonna put like a
disclaimer because there's like a whole
legal thing i'm not trying to get
involved people are saying that like
it was like this coordinated takedown
and not like a genuine
um response response to the products but
then people are also standing by the
claims like
i don't know what's true i don't know
what's not that's why it's too
complicated for me to even get involved
in but
um well it's interesting that it's that
it's at the court level now because the
courts
should be the ones to figure i will
leave it in the court's hands
yeah interesting um but to the james
charles things he
he uh released a video yesterday on
april fools where he actually had to
address like this is not a joke but like
i just didn't want to wait any longer to
address
some of the claims being made about me
um and it was called i'm holding myself
accountable
there's been and i follow on tick tock
there's been like two minors in the past
like year who have come forward and said
that like james charles has been like
inappropriately
flirting with them on snapchat and
instagram dms um and so james basically
made a video i watched most of it saying
that
he asked both of them how old they were
they both said they were 18 and he found
out later on that they were younger than
than 18. and therefore it was like
really an appropriate
way to conduct yourself um
like it was like actually like a really
weird video because he was like i was
just like thinking to myself like
why do i find myself in these situations
and he's like i had to come to the
embarrassing conclusion that i
i'm desperate and like that's like
okay maybe that's like a valid point but
like what does that have to do with
literally anything we're talking about
here
so it was just a really bizarre video um
and also like
he had also responded to the miners like
on snapchat like
it's just like so messy so i was just
wondering if that's what you were
talking about so in case you're
interested in the youtuber drama um i
will keep your breast thank you for
keeping us abreast
um i i'm so not abreast no you're not
and i don't feel like more oppressed now
it's not like a juicy like the whole
tattoo thing like that was a juicy
scandal
worth staying invested in staying
abreast on
this is like yeah i would have i assume
like if it was something that i needed
to really be
like double-breasted you would send it
to me
yeah yeah okay but speaking of what the
18 year olds are up to
bad baby claims she banked one million
dollars on only fans in just six hours
setting a new record i think you mean
behavior
bad bobby just turned 18 and took
her adulthood to only fans where she set
a record for
one million dollars in six hours tmz had
reached out to only fans to confirm if
this was real or a prank
and they said it is real not an april
fools it's just so funny that you have
to like confirm everything i didn't even
think of that because she put
she posted like a screenshot of her only
fans app so it looked super legit i
didn't think it was fake at all yeah no
but like they
i guess anything could be faked and i
don't think people thought it was fake
but they just like
let everyone know the subscription price
for her channel is
23.99 per month and you guys might
recall that bella thorne previously set
the only fans record last year
by earning one million dollars in 24
hours so this was in six hours
oh i thought bellathorne had done two
million so so bad baby
had behaved broly now is officially the
record holder
record holder wow i wonder who'll break
it next maybe it'll be us
titty pic um happy for her know that i
am she is really i have to say
she's not my cup of tea but she's really
star
she like she has taken herself quite far
from that cashmere outside how about
that like i don't know if you know like
there's a really popular song and it's
like viral on tech talk and i had no
idea that it was her singing
gucci flips up my socks
like i don't know the words because i
can't understand anything she says
but it's like a banger like she's like a
serious people like take her seriously
as a rapper
somewhat seriously okay yeah no and like
credit where it's due
i agree plenty of people go viral on
talk shows you know they have their
moment
and she has turned it into a career and
so it was dark for a minute when she was
like literally getting into fights with
like little vicky
on the street and like it was just like
dark
i'm just unfamiliar by the way lil vicki
i don't know if they call her that
anymore but maybe it's just vicky
she's she got big she's everything
medium-sized vicky
jackie she's everything like she was a
dunil bregoli like a
like a bad teen you know but she's
hilarious and i like live for her and i
listened to her on a podcast and she was
being so funny
you really shouldn't judge people i'm
dead serious like i
had many thoughts about her when i saw
her getting into fights with denim
goalie on the street and i think i was
fair in my judgment i'm not gonna lie
but i kind of held on to those judgments
for a while until i saw her on this
podcast
she was so funny and so fresh and i
really enjoyed it so
don't judge people okay i mean i don't
know
who like i've never have you seen the
tick tock trend i was like
two alone twill
tarting owning no she like counts
because she talks very strangely
um she counts and it literally does not
sound like the sound like english and it
was so funny it went viral
wow okay so the kids are up to yeah the
kids have gone wild happy for a bad baby
like she's really um raking in money
like left right and center i feel like
i'm always hearing things about like her
financials
she also became friends with billy
eilish which is no easy feat no and she
said from now on i'm gonna do whatever
the [ __ ] i want because now she is an
adult and
like because she got famous for being
like a kid a bad teen a bad baby
a bad miner a bad baby literally
don't make sense um she had like a lot
of messy things with like her mom well
and that's why she was on doctor phil
yeah right oh dad she literally got
famous for she's also coming for dr phil
now do you see
what is she saying so the facility that
she was like sent to
um to kind of like rehabilitate herself
from dr phil which is the place that dr
phillips sends a lot of his clients
is like being investigated and she's
like whole trying to hold
dr phil accountable it's giving me very
much um like paris hilton
yeah vibes of that type of facility like
for girls
interesting yeah i haven't i haven't
heard dr phil's retort though
wow well that actually leads into our
next story does it
yeah because morgan stewart is clapping
back at critics to defend her post-baby
body
which is so sickening i will take that
for a pre-baby body okay
a hundred percent morgan stewart posted
the most sickening photo of her
six weeks postpartum and i guess
that um people are upset with her for
setting like an
unrealistic standard so one twitter user
commented defending both sides i think
morgan was feeling good and was proud of
herself on the flip side too many
celebrity moms
portrayed this unrealistic view of
motherhood when the majority of mothers
don't have the time
money to hire someone or have tweaks
done or energy to do this
and so she wrote back to be clear i
didn't hire anybody
or spend money to help me get to where
i'm at six weeks later
i just went for a walk every morning and
was more mindful of what i consumed
i'm not going to withhold my successes
just because it may not agree with
others
okay so here's the thing i
i see both sides of this issue and like
not to be like this is so
unfair but it really just depends on the
person like so like when emily
radekowski did it i'm like oh my god
it's so out of touch
but when morgan stewart did i'm like yes
queen live your best [ __ ] life
so like that's just me being unfair um
but i do feel like
it's literally nobody's business like
and especially when we're in the
business of like not body shaming people
although it's not like you you can't
body like you can't speak on someone's
body i'm sorry like whether you like it
or not
you think it's great it's not your
[ __ ] business no it's like it's
it applies to all categories and so
i agree with her and she should not
withhold her success
just because someone may not agree with
it and i'm so on her side
like i mean whatever you look like at
six weeks pope hardem will whatever you
want
whatever you look like at any time like
you should be
proud i completely and you should not
not post it because what
people are going to think and that
applies to whether you are
quote-unquote thin or not you know and
i'm totally on morgan's side but again i
have to be very transparent with our
audience like if this was someone else
like
i might have a different perspective and
so i can't really know
i'm very biased here i just have to put
that out here because i love morgan
stewart i want the best for morgan
stewart i think morgan stewart's amazing
and whatever her decision is i agree
with it you know
okay but i don't really have like an
opinion on the philosophy here because
i'm so biased
i really am well we appreciate your
honesty i'm just being honest like
i can't get mad literally morgan stewart
cannot do one thing that would make me
mad like i literally live breathe and
die for her
yeah no i agree but i think on the
philosophy here
i i support whatever pictures anyone
wants to post to themselves in any state
of how they're feeling
i i agree with that philosophy
arbitrarily yeah but if it were family i
don't know
like it's just be different like i don't
know just like when morgan stewart does
it it's not annoying does that make
sense to anyone else like
certain people are annoying and some
certain people aren't no i hear what
you're saying like when it's your stance
like they can do whatever they want yeah
i'm really loyal like okay but like i
feel okay and i maybe so maybe i'm
seeing it like through the morgan but i
also don't think any woman should ever
have to
second guess about putting up a picture
of her body like regardless of if you
just had a baby or if you're emily
radakowski like i do believe that so
yeah and i feel like i've been seeing on
my instagram
like a lot of um new moms who are just
like
snapping back and and it doesn't bother
me and i've also like it just doesn't
bother me in any way no it doesn't
bother me at all i obviously like love
to see someone struggling because that's
gonna be me like
no not that's not what i mean i just
meant like someone who's like very who
doesn't bounce back immediately and has
more of like a
quote-unquote normal like i thought when
rachel parcell
um posted postpartum was like perfect
like she was really honest about
all of her workouts and her belly and
like that to me like that will be me
like i will not be morgan stewart so
i happen to relate more to the content
of people who don't bounce back so fast
um but that's just me but that doesn't
mean that the other content like has
it's less value like it shouldn't be
posted allowed yeah 100 okay are you
ready for our fifth and final story wow
today's
um episode is very like young people
heavy yph
yes it's a yph episode i don't want to
jinx it but can we just acknowledge how
good b-r-u-c-e is being
he's so good i didn't think he was good
i think i thought he was going to be
dennis the menace running amok like
dennis menace he's so good i'm so proud
of him like
he's just making mom look so good i know
i just
bruno if you're listening i love you
okay our fifth and final story is
is layered because one there's a new
descendants coming movie coming out
summer 2021 okay and sophia carson is
saying it was incredibly difficult to
film descendants yes
the royal wedding without cameron voice
so this is the fourth one
this is the fourth one i had no idea
there was even going to be a fourth one
you said that the third one was the
worst movie you ever saw and that's
coming from you who has like a very high
threshold for bad movies
hurtful hurtful heartfelt wait why was
that hurtful i think that's a good thing
but i did say that
you did and you do have a high threshold
like you will watch a whole bad hallmark
movie and like i literally won't that's
true i actually watched a whole bad
movie last night
um but it's that but it's like a good
movie that i found too bad i watched
elizabeth with kate blanchette and it
was just like
you're on like such an elevated content
play this like past few weeks mary queen
of scots like
queen victoria elizabeth um
well i'm literally watching like reading
colleen hoover and watching cartoons
because i'm an 11 year old no but like
there's just phases and seasons of your
life you know and
we're just in like this tudor era can't
get out
can i get out but i've moved on to the
elizabethan era oh good you're moving up
in history
yeah no um except now i'm gonna make a
little back with mary queen of scots but
the movie like was just like so bad and
stunk and
oh sorry we were talking about
descendants we oh but i'm sorry
elizabeth the movie
but you watch it i finished it because i
just wanted like i started it and then
you know what's crazy so i started it
two nights ago on amazon
no problem last night i went to pick up
where i left off all of a sudden i have
to rent it
and did you rent it the first time no
overnight it be it went from being
amazon prime to amazon pay
they do some of that [ __ ] sometimes i
swear to god because with you and me so
foolish paid yeah with twilight like
sometimes they're on prime and sometimes
they're not
and i've i've purchased them many times
somehow they always disappear from my
library
they pull that [ __ ] it's like an amazon
algorithm thing like it's the same thing
like
they like know you're watching something
and now they're going to charge you for
it like i'm sorry
you're amazon that's like some gin shot
telemarketing
like business model her arraignment is
today the phone number for zuma's going
around
it was at 11 a.m eastern time which is
when we film otherwise like
maybe i would have tried to join oh yeah
it's 11 30. um
wonder how it went should we should i
see if there's like an update or
anything oh yeah see if there's a master
post
okay um but back to the descendants
sophia carson is sharing the incredibly
difficult experience of filming the
upcoming disney movie descendants the
royal wedding without her late co-star
cameron boyce
as you can imagine she said how
incredibly difficult it was for us to do
this without cam
we just hope that when people watch this
they feel happy and they feel connected
to the characters and of course to our
cam
also she had said in the past that she
couldn't imagine like doing them right
without him and so it kind of like feels
weird
it does feel like they did a fourth
movie when like it was a trilogy when
you didn't have to like i always think
like a similar comparison is like glee
when cory monty passed away like it was
a show they had to keep going you know
but with the trilogy like you really did
not have to make another movie
and like the last movie it was that i
never even thought like
it was a final it was final yeah i don't
want to spoil it but
like they they brought everyone back
from the aisle oops
i don't want to spoil it but i think i'm
going to spoil it so like and i'm
excited to get a royal wedding because i
love mal and ben like they are just
everything
but i was like all set especially when
they like trash the franchise with the
third movie sorry
um gen shaw update um people who were on
the call like freaked out because she
literally said one word when she had to
plead not guilty
um so the peeps are freaking out but she
did plead not guilty to
uh money laundering and wire fraud
charges
okay to both counts now the courts will
do their thing
yeah they're calling it the arrangement
charainment
wow that's really good there's just so
much that like shock can be put into
like a narrative like because honestly i
was shocked
when i heard this news beyond yeah
beyond
um so those are the best five stories
really quickly um since oh we have to
talk about kind of kardashians but
did you see that theresa judice joe
judice and teresa's new boyfriend
and all the kids are together in the
bahamas yes and i that's where they
brought up because i spent like a lot of
time stalking the entire family last
night
all of the girls adriana is bella hadid
like totally um
gabriella doesn't have an instagram and
like i was like so
wanting to stalk her because it's
interesting like she's
i mean they're all so stunning yeah but
they all really all look alike except
gabriella looks
like them but a little different so i
was like like melania and gia
are theresa and adriana and gabriella
are
joe like they're they look like two sets
of twins yes but audriana also
looks a lot like theresa where as
she also looks like gabriella but then
it's but then gabriella sometimes like
doesn't look like gia
yeah i don't think what people like say
about us i can't wait to see more of
the uh relationship between i think his
name is louis and teresa and i think
it's like so nice that they're all like
co-parenting mingling and they can get
together in another country the bahamas
so i hope they had the best time i
really do even though like even though i
literally like hate theresa with the
intensity
of ten thousand sounds like i really
want the best for her her family joe
her kids like i really and i mean that
like sincerely but just as like a
character on the show like i despise her
a hundred percent i think that's like a
really
fair and you just compartmentalize yeah
and
i think that they are having like the
most amazing time on the trip like the
pictures are so sickening and like i
just know like gia is like so happy you
know no
and i'm so happy for gi i feel like
melania is so happy and like they're
happy their mom is happy they're happy
that they're
that they're with their dad we just need
to get joe like a nice italian
girlfriend
yeah also like i was just looking at
their instagrams and like it just seems
like they have like really
happy full lives like melania's on cameo
if anybody wants like a birthday i don't
know
and so i just am like so happy for
for the judice family me too but it is
also weird that like teresa is posting
pictures of joe
judith when like last night joel gorga
was like stop when joe judicia was like
kind of
like the catalyst and he wasn't even
there but like of conversation yeah
and the fight yeah and like they want to
be rid of him and they thought that they
were and now like they're all in the
bahamas like one big happy family i know
but he is the father of their children
and that's just like they're linked
forever so like
it does put teresa in a predicament but
she handles it very poorly
yeah great um okay let's talk about
keeping up with the kardashians with uh
really a terrible episode okay half good
half bad the push celibacy like eyes in
the back of my head
i didn't even i literally like when
courtney hears the moaning and like goes
and he's rubbing her back that was some
of the worst acting i've ever seen like
literally hallmark could never okay
hallmark would never don't even bring
them into this and sully their good name
but yeah usually when i'm watching like
i really try and watch
i was having full conversations phone
calls like during those parts
i was so interested and invested in the
spartan race like i was watching with
zach and i was like really who do you
think's gonna win
i did have my money on the kardashians
because they trained so hard but when
kim dropped out it was over
i know but like then i was like okay
maybe chloe could win because like she's
strong and she trains hard too um but
then like when all of my
pride hinged on courtney i'm like i said
to myself if courtney beats kendall like
i would be so happy like it will clear
the slate me too
but of course she didn't yeah but it
wasn't her fault because she's shorty
and you know what we can relate so i was
like
i it just once again courtney's like
rising in the ranks of my heart
yeah and i really want them to have a
rematch like where kylie
and can participate because it's true
like the jenners they
are these amazing athletes but the
people in their blood
are beasts like literally like ryan
lochte
versus michael phelps if you'll allow me
to explain yeah
no i think i know what you're gonna say
like michael phelps was
born to be a swimmer like he was
naturally gifted like he
he didn't even have to train and he
could have won gold medals no and like i
once watched this thing about him where
it's like even the proportions of his
arms back length
it's like very similar to that of a fish
unbeatable
yeah no but he's like meant to swim stop
like a fish i'm literally not kidding no
and that's what i heard
to me he's the jenners like it's in
their blood even if they don't train
like they have that athletic ability
whereas like the kardashians are ryan
lochte like they're not built
you know to be athletes but they work so
[ __ ] hard to get to the same level as
the michael phelps aka the jenners
yeah that makes sense yes i agree i but
i don't con
when i think of ryan lochte i'm not like
oh he works so hard like oh i do
i really yeah like that was like the
whole thing it was like michael phelps
had it so easy and then he was like
smoking sativa and he was like giving
away his gift
like we're like ryan lochte was like
working so hard his gift i i don't i
kind of in like
i miss ryan lochte and like michael
phelps like those were the best days of
our lives
i know i hear your comparison i feel
like there's a better one out there
i think mine's pretty good maybe it's
like tanya harding nancy kerrigan
yeah but they were both incredibly
gifted yeah but just different
backgrounds that's not the same
yeah that's not the same but i yes
there's like the natural gift versus
like i'm gonna work for work for it yeah
so at least that's how i perceive the
whole michael phelps ryan lochte thing
but anyways
um when courtney didn't win i'm like
okay of course you didn't win um and
when kylie didn't show up
uh of course you didn't show up and i
like that they don't even pretend like
she actually had a satisfaction like
they were just like laughing about it
like haha kylie doesn't show up anywhere
that was i i chose to believe that she
had a sinus infection
but um if she really just didn't show up
i'm incredibly disappointed no she
definitely just didn't show up they
didn't even like they were like
definitely just hung over no what does
like having a stuffy nose have to do
with
running yeah like it's obviously not
ideal but you do it yeah kayla had like
a whole doctor's note i believed him
of course she wanted to do it so badly i
really wish and i think she would have
won
you think yeah but she's also short but
she's a beast like
they were all just being so delicate
about it like with the spartan like you
gotta get
dirty you know i thought they did really
good like i was really impressed i was
actually surprised though that it was
only two and a half minutes like
yeah because that was a long ass set of
stairs taking two and a half minutes the
stairs would take me an eternity it
really made me like want to
do one like with our family it didn't
have the same effect on me
really i know it was one of those like
contrived story lines but i was
living for it yeah so like that's why
last night's episode was was frustrating
because
usually like the main storyline is like
something actually what's
actually happening and then there's one
and maybe two subplots but the main
storyline was this contrived spartan
race which was like so silly
i genuinely was living for it and i just
really wish that a kardashian had won
and like me too
it's just not fair no it's just not fair
um like the whole scot and courtney
thing is also so silly and maybe if she
wasn't like head over heels in love with
travis barker i might have believed it
for two [ __ ] seconds
but i don't and i just want to see that
i if i don't get like a
and no if i don't get a like moment like
acknowledgement of travis on the end of
the season or the new hulu show like i
love them so much like i've been
obsessing
i've started following that skinny but
not fat on instagram and she's like
obsessed with courtney and travis like
she's gotten me obsessed with courtney
and travis
to the point where like i stand so hard
and i know like all about the
intricacies of like the daughter and
like alabama the whole thing like i'm
obsessed
and i just need some of that because
like this whole fake story line like
scott district it's just not working no
it's not working i
am not escort shipper like i
i'm liking courtney more and more and
i'm enjoying
that experience and i love scott and in
no way want to see them together
yeah no not at all like the whole
swedish flag thing was so stupid
so stupid and by the way i ship scott
and sophia and that is where i
rest my ship i skip ship scott and
someone age-appropriate and i'll take
who i can get no
i i agree but like for me
it's it's sophia you know because he
doesn't want it he doesn't want to be
with someone age-appropriate so he has
to still be interested and like now
sophia is like
older and they had years under their
belt and i just felt like she was such a
great addition to the family i thought
she was a great addition to the family
too like her friendship with kylie was
great
but unfortunately that didn't work out
now it's like all the sisters like
shipping
scott and courtney and it's like where
were you yeah and where were you like 10
years ago
no it's like kendall are you friends
with sophia this is going to break her
heart
is she friends with sophia kylie is they
actually know they all say
yeah yeah i mean it was a totally like
fine boring episode
next week is when they talk about like
courtney's new friend addison ray who
sleeps in her bed
i'm so excited i forgot about that so
excited like
addison on keeping up like can't even
i'm so excited me too it's gonna be good
you guys make sure to tune in next
thursday
night night central um anything else was
happening
oh even better which is so nice and then
i could watch elizabeth it was a waste
of time but i could watch a movie is
there anything else you want to say to
the people before
we let them go and they see us on monday
and we can eat our donuts
um no i just want to say i actually i do
want to say a few words
um this week episodes were so good oh my
god
like confidence literally like laughing
like i just feel like it was such a
great week of episodes
and um it's because we were like back in
the studio we had so much to give and so
like we're rounding out just a great
week of toast
so if you like are trying to make
someone in your life a toaster like this
is definitely a great week to send them
also like with the gen chav at all like
there's just so much to breaking news
yeah breaking news i just want to give a
shout out to
bruce because he was so good mommy looks
so good
and i'm just so proud of him he's really
being like tea
so i listen
to all of our jewish toasters and a good
friday and a happy easter to all of our
celebrating toasters
and to those with no holidays to
celebrate this weekend go out and get
drunk with your friends
um have an amazing day amazing weekend
don't forget to get down on friday
don't forget don't forget to acknowledge
the space that you're in yes
we have a whole weekend ahead of us
acknowledge that and listen to your body
cultivate your vibe so important
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio
iheartradio cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcast find us
the morning chosen leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are if you want
your beautiful stunning and smart merch
head over to shopmorningchest.com um oh
i just want to give like a little
programming update speaking of merch
beautiful setting smart redheads i
always think like when we say things
after the thank you so much for
listening like no one listens because
people turn off the show
i agree but now like the more we talk
they'll be like more time
yeah let's just like give it a second
like or let's be as wordy as we can okay
so i totally agree because i'm like
there's literally no point in saying
something after
the wrap up because people don't listen
to the wrap up they just turn it off no
but i think like if you're
sitting in your car you just like let it
play out until it goes like whatever
you're gonna listen to next
i'm actually curious to the podcasters
of the world like do you
turn it off like if we say something
after the wrap-up like is it totally
useless
is it totally lost but this is what i'm
going to say and um
okay so um redhead's drama oh yes
keep up keep us abreast the book that
snitch chose
like literally doesn't exist anywhere
you can't get it on the kindle you can't
get it on amazon it's only available on
like google books
apple books so we chose a new book we
are reading twice in a blue moon by
christina lauren
and i had to like add it to the end of
the episode so it's like the episode and
then no one's listening to the add-on
um so if you are a redhead and you're
listening and it's a snitch's choice
which by the way i did these polls on my
instagram last night like oh yeah what
has been yours
i voted but i hadn't read a lot of the
books what did you vote for like the
ones that i had actually read
nothing to see here mm-hmm which i loved
yeah um and there was maybe like one
colleen hoover
layla but you know i knew that no yeah
so i really couldn't participate oh okay
so it was just really interesting to see
what people's favorites are and i think
by far and away the number one is before
we were strangers
which was a snitch's choice no yes yes
um so everybody loves the snitch's
choice truly and that's
something like a why a book that makes
you feel warm and fuzzy inside and so
like i know it's always a good time to
become a redhead and you don't want to
like prioritize one time over another
but a snitch's choices it's inaccessible
it's an accessible entree
into the redheads so twice in a blue
moon by christina lauren
pick it up read it join us that's a cute
book maybe i'll read it too yeah
um so yeah this is the end of the show
now bye
bye